j'ai jamais fait ça et tu me trouves
comment par rapport aux poteaux là
disons que tu maîtrises bien photoshop
je rappelle que tu avais me sens de
l'humour dans la description
ouais mais là c'en est pas bonsoir
bonsoir
alors ce soir nous vous proposons un
risotto aux morilles et un collant free
agrémenté de cette délicieuse vignes de
trucs curieux croustibat sent fautif un
très drôle c'est une blague mais je vais
vous prendre des petits bouts de vaches
puis agrémenté de ses fines lamelles de
pommes de terre sur son huile de palme
connard pardon
ok j'ai compris le cas ce soir et de
mère dans un resto de mai avec moi oh
merci beaucoup monsieur voilà vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée je peux
vous offrir un verre tu sais je suis pas
l'habitude de faire ça mais j'ai passé
un très bon départ et que ça allait
marcher
tu es un génie mon pote demain c'est moi
qui fais le serveur alors tu as bien qui
fait ça s'est super bien passé sérieux
là rien vu de bien c'est moi qui prends
le costume
il reste deux capote dans la poche